Alexandra cane is used to people judging
how she looks on the reality TV show
love island she signed up for scrutiny
but what happened after the show made
her self-conscious and insecure when I
came out the villa I was receiving quite
a lot of messages from cosmetic
companies offering me filler rhinoplasty
Brazilian butt lifts numerous things
Alexandre said no to the offers which
she never asked for in the first place
but if she had said yes the procedures
would have been free in exchange for
promotion on her social media channels
reality TV fame has brought Alexandra
more than a million followers ten times
that of the prime minister she's aware
of the influence every post has and
questions the ethics of unsolicited
offers of unnecessary cosmetic surgery
there's a part of me that feels like are
you trying to tell me I've got a problem
are you trying to say that how I look is
not living up to the current beauty
standards or that I should be following
the trends everybody else is following
we got in touch with the companies that
had messaged Alexandra only one replied
canvas cosmetics said in an industry
with so many gray areas and lack of
regulation honest reviews from
influencers who continuously returned to
us is what the public needs to find a
reputable esthetics company new research
shows a rise in the number of under 25s
having cosmetic surgery because they see
their favorite celebrities doing the
same on social media and often what they
see isn't the full picture the
consequences of having some of these
procedures can be physically and
emotionally life-changing in a
disastrous way you only have to Google
complications of fillers to see people
have gone blind or with bitter than
those dropped off social media is full
of posts of influences having a plump
here or a tuck there it's a powerful
promotional tool that Alexandra wants
that power to be used more cautiously
I'm all for everybody with doing what
they want to do
their bodies but when you're receiving
messages and it's offered that you want
to play I sometimes feel like those
decisions aren't necessarily based on
because you you really really want them
it's because they're just being offered
to you and that can that can be very
dangerous Katarina vertice Sky News